Game of Thrones became such a phenomenon
that especially this last season people
were making the biggest deal out of the
smallest thing there was this coffee cup
on the set they got left in a scene and
the word got out people started blaming
you for it
I don't just will defend yourself okay
so I'm gonna defend I hear this every
day of my life this coffee cup thing so
it's good to know that the coffee cup
got more press in the final season all
together the coffee cup was where kits
chair was at first I blamed it on Amelia
but I don't think of me Lea would do
that kit is lazy and I think he would
have done that it was in front of kits
chair and then obviously he moved so
this picture was taken and it looked
like it was in my seat but I wasn't
there either
it was kit it was a hundred percent care
and you're saying you're part of your
defenses you don't drink a lot of
liquids on the set for a specific reason
yeah because I wear a corset and so you
know I piss myself where I throw up yeah
so I just got a you know not really so
you're saying it couldn't have been you
cuz you're not drinking coffee on the
sides that play and does this kit wear a
corset on the show kit doesn't wear a
corset it's kid it's catch game and it's
not Amelia Amelia buys of course it to
it's a hundred percent kit yeah